about to give a talk to the bandwidth
football team national champs I'm a
national champ feels natural
you got your perspective sup fellas
thanks thank you for having me I'm super
honored look I'm gonna set some
framework I think when you come and
speak when you do something like this
my biggest agenda in here is to bring
you guys value you guys are busy you
could be doing something with your time
I don't need to be wasting it so what
I'd really like to do is create a
framework that allows us to do some Q&A
so I can answer some direct questions
whatever is running through your mind
let me give you a little context because
I know the far majority of you have no
idea who I am I was born in the former
Soviet Union I came to the US when I was
three we moved to a studio apartment in
Queens I lived with eight family members
in a studio apartment slightly bigger
than the stage that I'm on now my
parents grinded I didn't see my dad
until I was like 14 my mom and I kind of
put it together you know walking two
miles no car all that kind of stuff so
it was a real humble beginning
eventually my dad became a manager in a
liquor store in New Jersey so we moved
to Jersey that's where my
entrepreneurial hustle started when I
was six I was running four or five
lemonade stands I convinced tricked
whatever you want to call it my friends
in the neighborhood to stand there all
day I would make signs and look at cars
and try to make money
ripping flowers out of people's yards
and selling it to them selling rocks
baseball cards lemonade washing cars
shoveling like I was I was very unique
for all the immigrants that came from
Russia because education was the way out
and for me my DNA just didn't pull me
that direction so I was a DNF student
growing up but when I was 12 13 years
old I was making two three thousand
dollars a weekend because I was flinging
baseball and football on basketball
cards so that's just who I was and now
in this day and age the entrepreneur is
cool like people that's what people want
to be people
make that money when I was growing up
when I was your age or at least half
your age the only route out was school
and so frankly I was [ __ ] on my whole
life right even my friend's parents
didn't want me hanging out because I was
dragging their kids into bad school
different things there was just it made
no sense to me the thought that I was
being so successful off the school field
and yet that wasn't being viewed in an
any good way and so that was my life I
went to a tiny school called Mount Ida
college in Newton Mass I was in my
freshman dorm room in September of 94
playing Madden 95 my friend rolls in I
was dominating in Madden using the old
school team using Joe Namath in the 69
Jets
it's my squad my man walks in he goes
you got to come see this I walk in and
it was the first time I saw the internet
you know you guys are youngsters you're
not gonna remember this but some of the
coaches and the soul timers we remember
the cool couch guy that [ __ ] and I sat
there watched it and within the first
five to seven minutes I could feel that
I was looking at something completely
different and I waited for an hour this
how old school this was I had a wait an
hour before it was my turn to go on the
Internet
I went on and within another thirty
minutes I was on a bulletin board
selling cards and I realized my dream of
opening up 10,000 liquor stores wine
shops across the country because my goal
and still as I sit here today as a 42
year old man my goal is to buy the New
York Jets and the way I've thought about
that was I was gonna open up 10,000 wine
stores flip it sell it buy the Jets in
that moment in September of 94 I was
like wait a minute
I don't need to do that I'm gonna use
this thing and from that day on to here
the Internet has been the foundation of
a lot of things I've thought about now
it's mature now but in the early days
when I launched the first e-commerce
wine business in America called
winelibrary.com people clowned on me
told my daddy was an idiot for letting
his kid do this look people thought the
internet was a fad
forget about social media or snapchat
the whole thing was a fad and so that's
how I came up
and in five years I built my dad's
liquor store from a three to a sixty
million dollar business I made it
everybody thought it was a whiz kid I
was in papers TV it was amazing and then
YouTube came out YouTube came out I
thought it was gonna be big
I started a wine show on YouTube because
I wanted to educate people about wine
and within the first six months it got
real big and then YouTube sold to Google
for two billion dollars and when I saw
that flip I kind of looked at it and in
an article it said angel investor Ron
Conway made all this money on a $25,000
investment and I said I've been so right
about email and Google and the internet
the next time I feel it I'm gonna invest
and so in 2006 the first three companies
I invested in were Facebook Twitter and
Tumblr yeah I'm super [ __ ] rich so
that worked and then and then my brother
then my brother was graduating school in
2009 and even though I'm rich and I made
it and I did a good thing I like the
process I like the game I like being an
entrepreneur like some of you guys in
here love love playing others are just
cool with it it's your way out there's a
million different variables just some
people can't breathe without it I can't
breathe without the game can't breathe
without being busy I can't breathe
without working 15 hours a day I can't
breathe without every minute being
scheduled you know I woke up at 4:30
this morning with the Chicago met with
Kraft got on a plane here now with you
guys gonna drive to Atlanta tonight
because I got a meeting like just in it
just and I'm gonna be in studio with
Sonny digital to 3 a.m. tonight and then
7 a.m. be in a meeting so just in it
because I love my process I love my game
and and that is what I've been spending
more time on in the last 3 4 or 5 years
that's the thing I think I can bring
value here because you're all gonna have
different paths the thing that I become
fascinated with is where's your mind Act
write to me for example I'm gonna throw
you something I've been thinking about
on the flight down here to me the
craziest thing is that for most of you
your talent is your vulnerability and
not that like plays with my head the
fact that you're Tao
is actually your vulnerability because
it's been so given - you don't even know
any different I know you're talented
because I can contacts how fast you can
run what you can do what you can live
how you can play but your talent is the
vulnerability and to me how you get over
there and understand that for me what's
super interesting is on some straight
facts for 80% of you this is the apex of
your life you're a bama ballplayer like
most of you are not gonna be in the
league that most of you are definitely
not going to be in a league for more
than three years just math and so what
do you do with all the leverage you have
right now you know to me I think a lot
about when I talk to some of the kids on
DM and [ __ ] like that I don't think
about are they really leveraging their
moment do they understand while they're
the big dog on campus right now that the
kids sitting next to them in chemistry
class in six years is gonna have all the
leverage and they're not and they're too
cool to say hello to somebody and that
leverage can change the course of their
life and so for me you know when I walk
here I got a few minutes with coach he's
like what are going to talk about the
only thing that kept running through my
mouth is like who in here which fringe
special teams player which third-string
Lineback like who's gonna hear what I
have to say which is this is the
greatest era to ever be a lot alive
coach I others we didn't grow up with
this internet thing the access and
ability you have to do whatever you want
is extraordinary
it's almost uncomfortable but and it was
amazing my team couple guys on my team
are here we walk by and big sign the
hall said no excuses I just got so happy
like to me it's just a hundred percent
accountability like like to me this is
all about happiness like life happiness
to me this is just the easiest way I
know how to be happy is to blame myself
for everything
all of it and there's tactics you know I
was talking to coach about et it's he's
my guy coming through here like he's
like et challenged them to be off social
media for 30 days I was like why the
[ __ ] would he do that cuz that's a
tactic like that's short term right like
that's cool you check that box but the
reality is it's more about controlling
what's happening to me technology is the
great ammo for you
I hate when people talk about
Millennials and this and that like for
me this is it like this you guys are the
best at this you understand it the best
you are the best version it's always the
evolution but do you know how to make it
work for you that's a mindset game and
so I think about this all the time I'm
watching so many bike I'm getting 10,000
DMS a day right now for kids they're
coming from so many angles they don't
have enough so they resonate with me
like what I grew up with they have too
much and their parents are taking care
of everything like to me they're trying
to find their balance because there's
weakness and too little or too much and
so for me every day I'm walking through
this and I'm seeing it and I'm wondering
what is going through their mind what
are they thinking about because to me
the greatest leverage but what's crazy
about this program in comparison to all
the other places is the leverage you sit
with right now actually carries through
once you have that a on your patch like
you can play that forever but I'm just
watching kid after kid in programs that
have similarities or other things to not
leverage it as I'm in fact this is
actually I'm glad I get to tell this
story because this really hits home Dee
Milner was a create an incredible player
here
obviously I was super excited when he
went top ten to the Jets unfortunately
he got hurt and he was out of the league
at a league within two three years right
basically never really played in the NFL
for real obviously got very fortunate
cuz he was a top-10 pick to get some
money but he was in New York and I tell
all these guys when they come through
cuz all these guys know wouldn't become
a jet they can DM me and I'm gonna see
him and I tell him I'm like you're in
New York leverage it while you're a jet
I'll see you fifteen times I'll
introduce you to every CEO in the world
blah blah blah blah blah I'm like the
second you get trade and go to the
Packers I'm out I won't return your
phone call and that is leverage you have
and so for me life is very simple I
worked 15 hours a day in a liquor store
from 22 to 34 in a liquor store and I
lived in a studio apartment and bought
nothing no Supremes no off lights no
[ __ ] flat screens nothing interesting
I saved and saved and saved and then I
had my moment I saw the world was
changing the internet was evolving and
everything I had I'd have that much
in comparison I put it all in on
Facebook Tumblr and Twitter for me this
is my moment when I saw clarity of where
the internet was going and I went all in
I'll be very frank with you guys you've
got that right now like the level of
taking for granted what you're sitting
on is extraordinary the amount of
business men and women thought leaders
people that this place is religion to
are willing to have a conversation with
you
look at you totally different today than
they will in three or four years and
this you're managing your time you've
got so much to do between the classroom
and this there's so little time like
look I'm all about you playing fortnight
look I'm all about you talking to those
girls on DM I'm all about that I mean it
but allocating allocating time to
leverage your moment to understand what
you're actually sitting on with the
leverage of the brand that this has been
created that's something you can learn
here that you can use for the rest of
your life
to me the leverage of being a ball
player here like you are now and every
classmate wants to talk to you wants to
have some sort of relationship and I
know that 90% of them are gonna have
more leverage than you and five or seven
years I just want you to strike like
what you're too cool for somebody you
got to listen to your headphones and put
your hoodie on you can't say hello like
like I'm desperate for the guy that's
thinking that to just say yo you need to
go the other way to me the ROI of things
like college are the people people are
the game in life that's how life
actually plays out and so for me you are
in a remarkable spot right now and
you've got to do plenty of film study
and plenty of school and plenty of
taking care of whatever else you've got
to take care of but squeezing it is just
phenomenally interesting to me they
bounce on a couple other places and open
it up to Q&A I think the biggest thing
that I've noticed for the people that
are winning whatever that may be
money success in business life what have
you I think patience is a massive
foundation for them
I think patience has been extraordinary
thing for me to watch everybody just
wants it so fast you know and especially
when you're younger it just feels like
you want it so
it's tough to like you know to me when I
got in a school and I wanted to do all
these big things my cousin was 30 years
old in the liquor store and I was 22 and
I thought he was old as [ __ ] right just
eight years older to me if I realized at
that time how young he was if I could
make you feel the way I feel right now
at 42 I feel exactly like you I'm twice
your age it feels the same inside it
feels the same inside and the second you
would actually understand that or
believe it everything else starts
changing you start getting patient you
get way more meticulous you start
thinking about things completely
different and for me that's if like one
person could start really realizing the
patient's game that would make a ton of
sense for me let me let me bounce around
a little bit here I think one of the
interesting things I tried to do a
little homework is I appreciate that
coach is not cramping too down on social
and things of that nature but obviously
you want you to be thoughtful no
different than anything else right again
I kind of harped on a few minutes ago
about campus or people that are fans of
the program the amount of people you can
get to through DM on Instagram is
remarkable if you have interests if you
want internships if you're thinking
about things that you're excited about
in life like people gonna return your DM
being thoughtful about that about where
you want to go there's only these couple
moments in time I was there for early
Twitter early Twitter if you tweeted
somebody they replied about a year or
two later game over I'm real old email
back in 96 97 98 you emailed somebody
they replied you've got that moment for
about another year another half year
maybe two years on Instagram DM you need
to use that for your ambitions in your
future or whatever works here just be
very very thoughtful of the power of
people applying cuz they're gonna click
on your profile they're gonna see what
you're about and they're gonna reply so
I would highly recommend squeezing that
huge opportunity for me when I think
about all the things that have worked
for me it all comes down to perspective
right so after I made those three
investments later on about a year or two
later I was an early investor in uber as
well right and so
yeah but I [ __ ] up uber because I
could have been even earlier because I
was literally in the room when it was
invented in Paris by the two founders
but the first pitch of wouldn't it be
cool if limousines could pick you up if
you pressed a button on your phone
seemed a little too bougie and for the
1% and I think it was gonna be a big
business I didn't realize how it was
gonna play out but to me what it
represented is something that I think
you need to be thinking about which is
everything you're thinking about right
now literally in five to seven years is
gonna be completely changed between
augmented reality machine learning
cryptocurrency I'm sure some of you lost
some money on some Bitcoin you know like
all this stuff that's actually happening
like this internet thing this technology
thing is just starting it's just
starting it's gonna be completely
encompassing like the robots are gonna
kill us in the end right and so like
serious by the way and so better enjoy
it while we're living and so just
contextualizing what's going on and your
opportunities within it matter so much
and listen I'll be real frank with you
like I know people are sitting here like
you've got singular focuses I respect
that
honestly I've deployed massive empathy
where your mindset might be out and to
be very honest with you ultimately I
really don't care what you do right
you're not my sister you're not my mom
you know I just really hope that one or
two people can really understand that
you're sitting on unbelievable amounts
of leverage and the thing that I'm most
scared of one of the biggest reasons I
like spending time with really old
people retirement home stuff is if I
could give you a crazy left-field piece
of advice go one day to retirement home
and just help out if you see regret in a
man's eyes like real regret when the
game's over it will change the way you
navigate your life every day and to me
to be very frank watching all these 24
25 26 27 year-old football players DME
who had a cup of coffee in the league
who got hurt who watching there regret
of them not leveraging their three years
here
made me answer real quick coach when you
reached out real quick because I was
like man if I could just get one kid I
could just get the [ __ ] punter on
this team to understand that he can
squeeze it squeeze it you know like to
me it's just at a remarkable time of
your life and you will always always
think about it and so I highly recommend
you take a step back and you start
deploying massive gratitude on what
actually is going on here
you got to focus on this season I'm sure
plenty of you got a chip on your
shoulders I'm sure you put a lot of you
were hearing the whispers of like where
people think you're gonna play out what
you're thinking to play out so I'm sure
you're SuperDuper focused but to me one
step back and start deploying
perspective of what this moment your
life is and how much leverage you have
and how much opportunity the world has
and let me say another thing if you ask
me the biggest thing I'm worried about
I'm worried about the economy being so
good for so long we've had a good
economy now for nine years like all
these people that are your homies or
friends that are say there are
entrepreneurs on Instagram but they're
not really winning if you're not winning
as an entrepreneur right now you suck
because it's easy out there the
economy's super simple and so to me the
biggest concern looking at your age it's
highly likely that when you're 23 26 27
that the whole thing's gonna fall let's
get real tight and I talk to all these
30 and under entrepreneurs and they
think they're big shots and I always
tell them like the problem with you is
you haven't been punched in the mouth
yet because the last seven eight years
that you've been navigating the markets
been so remarkable so for me not only am
I thinking over the top about the
mindset of where you're at to me I'm
thinking about the playing field that
you're actually gonna live in in your
20s to 30s and then that just compounds
my energy of like be thoughtful like
network for real like figure out what
interests you have for real like of
course go for the lead and you do you
but you have enough talent to do all of
it and so I'm just thinking that this is
the time and I just hope that you don't
regret it and let it go by questions
my man
because I don't like the money coaches
won five championships what's he doing
look I love the game like I want the
admiration what am I doing here
I'll be frank with you you guys are cool
and all I'm looking for admiration I'm
looking for one of you to email me nine
years from now saying yo you came
through Bama when I was there you said
something about saying hello to people I
just said hello to somebody in class
because I don't know I remembered that
you were there and that person is now my
business partner we're winning I just
want to say thank you that's a high I'm
sure you get it at scale guys coming
back that's a ha I can't get off that
high I was on Breakfast Club about a
year ago two years ago and uh it was
going good and then NV was mad cuz
Charlemagne was being too soft on me so
he was like yo you're talking all this
motivational [ __ ] why don't you give
us a piece of good advice how's it go
damn like in so you know Devon radio so
I was like the only thing I went to is
what I grew up on like flip game I was
like look he's like well what if I only
have a hundred bucks I was like well
then you need to go to Goodwill or the
dollar store or Craigslist and buy some
stuff and flip it and I created this
whole flipped challenge and the amount
of people that made an extra five
hundred bucks a thousand bucks that it
really meant something to and getting
those emails I'm in it for a lot of
reasons one I want to buy the Jets so
I'm rich but I need a lot more right
that's number one number two I'd die if
I didn't work like to me my game my
passion like I love my family more than
life but my wife walked into my like
bedroom tonight and was like I need you
to stop working and be home she knows
that I'd be like look we need to figure
this out or we're just not gonna be
together I can't like it's not because I
don't love her I'm being serious I know
it sounds weird but I'm just telling you
I would suffocate I would suffocate and
so I'm in it for the game and honestly
I'll be honest with you I I think the
quickest way to get paper is to love the
process because you're not gonna be able
to work 15 hours a day if you're doing
it for some new Supremes it's too hard
if you don't love it
what it's a completion in the conscious
mind
or anything sensitive because we're also
changing
so what is it
in the crossing point
you know consciousness had a rose the
mindset how did I think about like going
straight to me that the big thing was
I'll tell you I think the biggest
vulnerability you've got is you actually
value somebody's opinion more than you
value your own like the reason I've been
able to always do my thing is when I was
24 and people were like oh you work at
your dad's liquor store like I heard
that it's like a chip on my shoulder you
know I loved it I was like cool keep
sleeping on me dick
you know like I'm glad you're on Wall
Street making a hundred thousand buying
BMWs and dumb jewelry I'll see you in 30
years you understand like to me the way
you win is you realize you can't hear
nobody not your parents I mean listen
you got to listen to coach and all that
should I get it but at the end of the
day my guy yourself you got to get real
real quiet up here
I can't hear anything you go look at my
Instagram right now my first post I'll
post something first hundred replies in
one second you're Jesus you walk on
water you're the best you're the
all-time can't hear him the next hundred
you're a piece of [ __ ] you're full of
[ __ ] you're a snake oil salesman can't
hear him I'm in my own mind doing my own
thing
and that comes with self-esteem
everybody's trying to keep up with the
Joneses I'm not worried about you being
on the [ __ ] in the Hamptons on a
blow-up Swan
I'm not worried about you renting out
cash from the bank and putting it to
your ear
I'm not worried you jump the fence and
took a photo in front of a private plane
what do you think these people are doing
they're posing patients long game you
know what's amazing about being an
entrepreneur we get to play forever
right you know that was the biggest
heard of smart and great football player
jet I met him he was like 34 he's got to
like rekindle his whole thing and I'm
like he's such a young man it's crazy
being an athlete having a reset the
great thing for me is I get to play
forever I'm gonna be working when I'm 96
trying to find my next hustle my guy
technology associated
oh so they need a connection like
connections are amazing for foundational
but if you're trying to build awareness
let's say you opened a bar a barber shop
you want to sell t-shirts like the one
big advantage you guys have look I have
a huge company my company's gonna do 200
million dollars in revenue I just flew
from Kraft we have Budweiser we have the
biggest brands in the world chase they
still don't get it I'm sitting the
meetings every day and they're not
pouring enough money into social media
that's your advantage they're still
pouring it into commercials and print
and things of that nature so you know
where the attention is and so social
matters but humans and relationships are
just honestly no man I said it like I
can't explain to you enough how much I
want you to meet every person look some
of you are introverts if you're an
extrovert and your social you need to go
all-in on the fact that you got blessed
with that DNA that you love people and
you love saying hello and you've got the
leverage of doing what you're doing now
some of you are introverts right and
that's hard but like I'm gonna keep
pushing to because the lever just absurd
my email Gary I actually know what this
will be way way better DM me at Gary on
Instagram Gary Vee yep Gary Gary Vee
just DM me there this way I won't lose
it good
yeah yeah the question was when I was
younger when I didn't have as much how
do I take the first step honestly this
is where I actually am you know with you
guys this is the one thing I connect
with like somewhere around third grade
was when I realized I'd be more likely
owning a team than playing for one but
for you you you know it was what your
natural skill was if you think I have
any idea why at five years old I went
outside and thought it was a good idea
to rip people's flowers ring their
doorbell and sell it back to them right
or like why when it snowed and everybody
wanted to make snowmen and sled I'm like
let's get to work and convincing my
friends to bring doorbells and shovel
that was just in me you know and
honestly that's another thing right like
you have so much talent at what you're
doing for a lot of you this is what you
should be doing but for a lot of you
there's other talents that you don't
even know you've never tasted it - the
other thing that I want to get people's
that go cook
go play eSport like do things just a
taste so that you get to know what you
might be about I just found my thing
early you know my guy just super early
worked out for me that way you know and
that's why I tell people like try stuff
like the reason people don't you know
what the reason a lot of your teammates
here don't do things they're worried
about somebody else's thoughts on it
they're worried like somebody's me like
you're corny like they give up like I
would think I would give a [ __ ] about
you calling me corny that's a stupid way
to live life
that's what people are doing out here
and in this room and this is a Bama
football players what do you think's
going on in the world insecurity is
driving people's actions
my heart's woman hurts no you know I
think my heart is you know I'd once I
started my career I guess I'm trying to
take a couple things you know first of
all you know why I'm even like pausing
on that I'd be really lying to you so
I'm just gonna keep it real I love know
I was at the top of the wine game and I
left because I won I didn't want to do
it anymore
and went into marketing where everyone
liked the first article written about me
was like this guy had wine Twitter I
think the article in the big advertising
magazine was Twitter boys what they call
me Twitter boy thinks he's gonna come
and win Madison Avenue ha ha ha ha
they're not laughing anymore you know
and even this game now I can already
feel it I'm like oh man three four or
five years from now this thing's a rap
I'm gonna be the guy someone have to
start selling oranges or something you
know I got to figure you know I've been
up to figure something out because I
lose like I'm about to climb back to
sports I grew up with diehard Yankees
Jets Rangers Knicks fan the Yankees and
Rangers won their championships I
literally stopped watching them Knicks
and Jets are gonna take me a minute you
know but like but like I'm just about
the color I just love the climb like
even like back to sports cuz I think
it's great analogy I'll turn on a random
game I need to know who the underdog is
that's my team I'm just about to climb
you know like to me when I see a kid
wearing a Steph Curry Jersey and that
kid lives in New York I think that kids
soft
I mean it he's he's using somebody
else's success to make himself feel good
I think the biggest tell of a losing
person is wearing a jersey outside your
own city it's a subtle thing I miss you
know obviously there's always maybe some
rationale but that's a [ __ ] I look for a
guy my face oh I understand encompass so
the question is my biggest burn I've
lost millions yeah of course
because you can't win without playing
right you got a risk so when you're
doing what I did back in the day it was
so early you were investing in people's
ideas so there was there was so tinder
right before tinder like ten years
earlier in the game a Lemieux nity there
was a app called Grindr and I was like
this [ __ ] is really gonna happen for
boys and girls I know it so I was
chasing one highlight I was chasing all
these apps that I thought could be the
tinder right there was one company that
I swore was gonna be bigger than
Facebook it was called yo Bongo I
shouldn't know and just on the [ __ ]
name but you know I mean I put a hundred
that listen I you know you have to Sam
when I was losing this money it was
tough for me because my Twitter and
Facebook and Tumblr stock hadn't made me
money yet so these like that fifty
thousand dollar check that went to zero
that [ __ ] hurt cuz I was bleeding for
that fifty you know but I've lost a lot
yeah I mean I'm just not scared I owe
you know why I'm not scared because I'm
not scared to go backwards like my
favorite Rocky is Rocky six when he
loses everything and goes back to the
hood in Philly like I'm not scared about
upward like you understand I like the
process I'm not worried about the
judgment like back to the first question
about the money it's just not even in my
mindset
my guy what's that yeah I've never
borrowed money the reefer barred money
because I think most people raise money
or with high interest rates because they
want [ __ ] faster
I want stuff slower the bigger the
ambition the more patience you have to
deploy so that worked out I didn't you
know a lot of this [ __ ] I didn't realize
at the time we just I talked about a lot
of this stuff now is like it's hindsight
I can look back and be like oh so much
came to be natural you know but I didn't
have to deal with interest rates cuz I
never looked to borrow money I was you
know I was willing to eat when I started
vaynermedia my company now it's gonna be
a billion-dollar company it started in
in a conference room in somebody else's
company cuz I don't want to pay rent but
I didn't because I wasn't worried about
people coming to see a fancy office
people are just fronting all the time
yes sir
I've never doubted when I made the
investment I'm not writing some kid a 25
$50,000 check because I doubt it you
know unfortunately in that game six
months later
forget about doubt you regret it the
biggest thing I learned was there was a
lot of fake entrepreneurs the biggest
mistake I made was I was coaching and
investing in thinking as if that person
was me and I learned like you know I
liked the idea I could see how they
could do it but they weren't me because
I'd look on their Instagram and they're
like at the beach on Friday afternoon
and the first time I see that photo I'm
like I'm dead because they weren't even
making money they borrowed money and the
audacity is enormous people go out of
business they write me an email dear
Gary you know sorry to inform you looks
like we'll be closing up shop our app
has failed we have seven thousand
dollars left that's entitled to you you
know we're really sorry but good news
good news I learned a lot and in the
future maybe we can do something and I
would reply be like good news you lost
my hundred thousand dollars [ __ ]
and there's just so much of that
entitlement you know and so that's in
the last three four years I've gotten
out I've been building my business
because there's so much fake
entrepreneurship in the game a guy
it's my life everyday it's running
through my desk I'm seeing pitches
I'm a full time guy Phil Toronto and my
team's looking at businesses but I'm
running a very big business right now
they're you know I have an office in
London I'm opening up one in Brazil and
Singapore next year so I'm so busy on my
own thing right now because I'm not
investing as much because I think
there's a lot of fake stuff
yeah I have a parent company called
Vayner X my vaynermedia I bought a
women's media site called Pierrot Wow
sort of dude site called 137 p.m. so I'm
putting in work yeah
I played that in college you know and
listen that's not what you should be
doing if I was lucky enough to come to a
place like this and I had those skills
to get this kind of education I would
have but that wasn't who I was like I
just was not a student my guy like just
I didn't have it in me you know even now
Marcus is standing over there my chief
of staff like he's got to keep me
focused on like every you know
self-awareness man right even on the
field for a lot of you self-awareness
know what you can and can't do that
really matters so and it was tough man
you know like when I was coming up
entrepreneurship was nothing now
everybody wants to be an entrepreneur
you know look but like it was tough but
I just couldn't hear anything you know
yes sir
[Music]
I certainly love it or need it I do it
because I want to spend time with my
kids now and things of that nature but
but it's a great question like to me
it's like you got to really figure out
who you are like whatever I got I just
have a ton of energy because I love what
I'm doing and it's just you know it's
momentum right but like if tomorrow I
felt burned out like I'm not scared to
take off and I love like Christmas or
the last two weeks of August when
everyone's checked out then I don't feel
any anxiousness that somebody's getting
off on me you know to me the problem is
I feel like somebody's doing something
and that competitive juice is kicking in
you know I'm sure you feel that with
what you do you know if I'm not in the
weight room somebody else's you know and
I feel that like and so I don't love it
in my I mean the biggest regret so far
in my life is in my 20s I did nothing I
worked every minute I did nothing and I
could have taken a couple vacations it
would have been nice to hang out my boys
once in a while I just so
well woody Johnson's not selling I don't
have two billion dollars yet so I'm not
worried about when he's gonna sell or
when he's not I'm just working on the
process but like I've I've had
opportunities to invest some in fact
ironically had opportunity invest in the
Dolphins which Steve Ross like I've had
some opportunities but I'm pretty
focused on I want to run it you know and
I want to be paid listen I'm thrilled to
buy the Jets at 74 like thrilled like if
you said that's what it is I'm like
amazing you know that's back to that
patience like I'm I need 20 30 more
years of wealth creation like a lot of
people ask me why I'm running the
business I'm run now cuz it's a crappy
business but I'm building the foundation
based on all my success I love the
process I know what I'm building right
like if I have your athletic ability
like I'd be in film room and weight room
I'll just be putting in the work it's
it's not complicated like you know what
you have to do to get there you know
you've got your talent we all got it the
variable is the mindset of how much work
you're gonna put in right and the other
thing is taking else I think most people
don't know how to take else and like
that's a huge part of how I think about
it
my guy
I think my mom / loved me for short like
just she told me I had it like that and
then honestly just the confidence came
from losing believe it or not you know
like I think the biggest problem we have
in America right now and we've got
plenty of problems but like eighth place
trophies are [ __ ] us up you know like
like I I I got confidence from taking a
ton of losses because then I figured out
what I was good at I'd rather win and I
kept honing in to that but I wasn't
scared to lose you know that was it
sneak one in
like and also with that being said a lot
of us were trying to think away there's
a sheep you know with us about
scholarship shakes and things like that
why don't realize that we won't be
playing NFL so we won't be making that
big when you come out so we're trying to
set a foundation now for the next 45
years to
I like that throw that out and throw
that up what do you think smart and
whistles don't have a lot of Amazon
Amazon like if you just put in Amazon go
to sleep you'll be really happy with me
that's one but I'm gonna tell you
something right now I'm gonna wrap it up
and put a nice little bow tie on it you
can if they gave you a hundred thousand
dollars here and you put it away that's
nothing compared to you leveraging the
fact that you play for Bama football and
you say hello to everybody on this
campus telling you right now man that's
the [ __ ] game thank you so much man
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]